TO MAKE.
RODMAN LOST SIGHT OF HIM, HE
THOUGHT HE WAS ON THE LEFT SIDE
,  WHEN HE ADJUSTED AND WENT TO
THE RIGHT SIDE.
HE WAS OPEN FOR THE LONG PASS.
>> Greg: BAMBA 67% FREE THROW
SHOOTER HITS THE FRONT END.
THIS ONE WHAT TIE.
TIED AT 7474, 23 SECONDS LEFT
TO GO.
AGAIN, PRESSURE.
>> Eddie: NOT SURE I WANT TO
PRESSURE IN THAT SITUATION.
AND LEAVE THESE GUYS BE OPEN
SHOT.
>> Greg: SCHEIERMAN , DOWN TO 10
TO PLAY.
ARE WE GOING TO OVERTIME?
OR WILL SOUTH DAKOTA STATE WIN
ON THE ROAD?
STEP-BACK THREE, MADE! GAME.
SOUTH DAKOTA STATE JUST OUTSHOT
WASHINGTON STATE.
BAYLOR SCHEIERMAN WITH THE STEP-
BACK THREE.
77-74.
>> Eddie: HE PUT IT SO HIGH IN
THE AIR.
FROM HERE, PERFECT ANGLE FOR US
TO SEE IT, THAT WAS ON TARGET.
GOING LEFT, BETWEEN THE LEGS,
DROPPED HIM A LITTLE BIT, LOOK
HOW HIGH THE ARC IS ON THE.
>> Greg: THAT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
ANDREJ JAKIMOVSKI HAD SLIPPED.
HE WAS UNABLE  TO CONTEST THE
SHOT.
SCHEIERMAN KEEPS THE DRIBBLE
ALIVE.
STEP BACK AND LOOK AT THAT, THE
LEFTY DRAINS IT.
>> Eddie: I TELL YOU WHAT,
THESE KIDS NOWADAYS LIKE TO SAY
GUYS GET THERE IN BROKE , RIGHT
THERE, HE COMPLETED THE
HIGHLIGHT.
HE DROPPED HIM AND DROPPED THE
THREE FOR THE GA